The trump supporters,
I'm a resistance to judging trump on his
merits,
of which there are none,
you know,
uh,
comes down in part to this with this
loop,
back to that rebellion against the
elites.
Now,
one of the things that,
there has been tremendous scorn for and
fun made of trump and in deed deed trump
supporters in when you are angry at the
establishment and you see the
establishment and not,
not just disagreeing with your
candidate,
but mocking or candidate.
There is an element of this is they're
mocking me.
They're mocking me.
All these people at the New York Times
going on and on about how does this is
impossible.
This horrible person cannot possibly be
president too.
They're saying that I am so,
you know,
because I support him,
they're looking down on me.
It's all these fancy college educated
people and I'm the one doing the hard
work,
you know?
And they're looking down at me.
And so there was almost every time you
went out to make fun of trump,
you increased to support because people
were feeling scorned.
You know,
when,
when people feel that they are
outsiders,
you cannot convince them by mocking them
and you can't convince them by mocking
their position,
the he,
we had to either wait for what seems I
hope to have happen for the guy's head
explode,
you know,
or we had to take,
some sort of other approach to,
to,
to this and say,
well,
you know,
let's,
let's look at it from this angle.
Or you know,
maybe this is a good reason to vote for
the Libertarian party or maybe it
anyway.
The scorn does not.
When,
when people feel scorned to heap,
scorn upon them isn't going to work.